it's fall [ __ ] let's make some leaf
crafts decoupage is that a real word the
[ __ ] does DQ pitch mean
decoupage bro can't wait for Christmas I
love that pine tree smell beasts leaves
smell like nothing see this is why guys
don't use pincers but I don't want to
read this yeah
yes we don't need these instructions
we're just gonna go for it this looks
like a big triumph that bastard I don't
know if I want this one
I'm gonna do my twine first I do like
the sponge brush though yeah it's nice
there's dust everywhere rope dust
there's gotta be more to this right this
is like it's not just glue and leads to
a jar is that is that we're doing here
is that it man it's kind of a big
therapeutic I like peeling the modge
podge from my fingers after it dries you
know I'm not mad at this you know what
what if I just wrapped twine around all
of it like a shipwreck or someplace like
a ship so did I win the mason jar Oh
suck thanks you try decoupaging is an
art you need to be very delicate and we
we're not that delicate no I would
definitely not put a picture of this on
Pinterest and be like look what I made
but [ __ ] that dude I would stand like
this with the jar like that on Pinterest
like one of these smiles like how the
[ __ ] does this work this what even is
this no one has ever ever needed this
cut the bag in three strips I'm just
gonna start cutting I think he is he
cutting at the wrong direction weak men
have doubts before decision strong men
have doubts after usually working in and
out dude calm down
that's good well I'm gonna make one that
fits my head this is a really bored
drunk mom we came up with this like I
don't know I just like take some bags
and glue these two and put them on your
hands did you go there did you okay
let's say if you took my leak something
awful this way comes
it'd be terrible if we like ended our
friendship and broke into a fight over
making leave hats and two of the same
color
let me just make it rain I made my crown
for you I've been good for you
sit on properly hmm doesn't fit strange
i crown you Pinterest all-star Zachary
how do you do that tea I must have bell
curls yeah dude he's like he's hats all
the way bad here
yeah there's no way to stays on it's not
bad you didn't all right Josh this one
is the first one that actually seems
like something you can use and not be
laughed at tap into the little
hunter-gatherer inside of you and forage
for leaves dot your yard and
neighborhood practice on an old cloth
napkin don't need to do that choose a
leaf and turn it over so the more veiny
side is facing I feel like I should get
some of this at home
I like this hack this is cool this one's
so much easier turn your leaf over and
carefully position on your cloth neck
and however you like it oh now this this
is what she doesn't tell you but this is
the most important part for her
I feel like Mission Impossible and I'm
Tom Cruise and I can't touch the floor
I'm feeling good I feel good I feel like
once I unveil this it's gonna look real
nice not slipping mine out you see this
is why you need a bro when your
Pinterest yeah I mean you could see it's
more subtle yes more sauce spear man oh
yeah dope I like it it's like a
spongebob squarepants character I want
to make a turkey and have all of my
family and friends over to come look at
my napkins cuz they're so cute
I think Pinterest is cool I think it's
an interesting place to share creative
ideas I would love to make some leaf
crowns with like my little cousins that
would be awesome
actually no this would be really good
this would be good to do which like your
mom Mother's Day like if I visited my
mom actually my mom would hate this I
would rather make it myself
than buy it at a store yeah I agree get
on with that yeah Lakers lost again yeah
yeah
I lost again it doesn't surprise me man
it's been a few years although they have
[ __ ] Stoudemire now Naz Lakers my
stuff nothing then I'm sorry Chris oh my
oh yeah I thinks Donna Myers done to you
Oh coach last year really good [ __ ] you